no country has ever attacked every other
country and that's what China has done
those are pretty powerful words what you
just said right there Beijing has really
worked very hard to prevent us from
learning what's going on what is the
level of accountability to them that all
the other countries can come out and say
listen you cost us a lot of money
Communist Party of China and the World
Health Organization helped spread this
coronavirus around the world how could
they not know about it I mean they're a
world health organization they've got
doctors what is the motive between World
Health Organization's protecting China
that's what I'm curious about
we need to get China out of the UN out
of the World Trade Organization out of
the World Health Organization and just
start to isolate it we relying on them
on Pharma we're relying on them on a lot
of different things I mean it's sickened
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world and it is not done with us yet
that is not a conspiracy theory this is
horrific did you ever think you would
you bet on July it but we got red tape
now you came in given values contagious
this world of entrepreneurs we can't no
value to haters run homie look what I
become
I'm the unborn
[Music]
so my guest today is Gordon Chang the
author of coming collapse of China who
lived in nearly two decades in China
you've probably seen all over TV
on a recent interviews regarding
coronavirus and the reason why I wanted
to bring him on board to do this
interview many guys requested it you've
obviously know a lot of different guests
that we've had but he comes from a place
of he went to law school Cornell
University he worked for two big law
firms in China I believe one is in Hong
Kong and he has a lot of different
experience to his perspectives gonna be
from a different standpoint and he
happens to be half Chinese his father is
from China and so I'm looking forward to
going into it with him so Gordon thank
you so much for making the time to being
a guest with us you're invited
well thank you so much Patrick so so if
I may get into it this is this is the
approach I'd like to take with this on
this interview and and the reason why
I'm taking this approach is the
following reason my Instagram account my
messages my email ever since we enter
interview general Spalding from the air
force which I think you two have worked
together on a couple different projects
and he knows of you you were recently in
a documentary together that came out a
couple days ago and he ended up getting
seven million views and people contacted
us all over the place so then we brought
onboard
Danielle DiMartino booth yesterday we
talked about the effects of coronavirus
to the economy and she it's just the
amount of commentary and people's
interest in it it's whole different
place but also at the same time a lot of
interviews on YouTube on Vimeo all over
social media have gone viral with us you
know Joe Rogan did it with Michael Ostra
hold or two David Icke with Brian rose
from London real that's gone all over
the place and the video has been taken
down from YouTube from Vimeo from a lot
of different platforms or general
Spalding or dr. Shiva or foutch or a lot
of names obviously people are curious
the direction I want to go with this is
the following I would like to bring up
all of these different conspiracy
theories that are coming up and for you
to say no there's no truth behind that
yes there is some credibility behind
that so you can either tell us zero
credibility behind
maybe 50% and that is not a conspiracy
that is an accurate statement so if you
don't mind us going through that
direction I think the viewers would like
to see it from a person that's a lawyer
Cornell University who's lived in China
for two decades and has been over here
maybe gonna give us a different
perspective are you okay with that
terrific okay so let's get right into it
so first of all is coronavirus real does
it exist
well it certainly exists I mean it's
sickened hundreds of thousands of people
around the world and it is not done with
us yet we tend to think that because it
is a corona virus that it will disappear
in the summer but we also know that this
bug likes hot weather so we're just
gonna have to wait and see because it is
surprising us day by day okay so yes it
is real number two is it a natural virus
that came from the you know wet market
where it's not man-made it's natural
that kind of happened or is it man-made
intentionally made to use as a bio
warfare chemical to go against an enemy
well so far the science says that it is
unnatural that it is there
it wasn't spliced there have been a
couple papers which have talked about it
being engineered but those papers have
not received general acceptance in the
scientific community but one thing
though that's really important Patrick
is that Beijing has has done it's best
to hinder foreign virologist and
epidemiologists from going into Wuhan
the epicenter and studying this the
World Health Organization sent a team
into China
they were there for maybe about two
weeks but they were only in Wuhan for
two days February 20th and 21st they
only were able to send part of the team
and and really they did not have the
opportunity to study the virus itself I
think these were more or less sort of
like get-to-know-you meetings so Beijing
has really worked very hard to prevent
us from learning what's going on and
because of that of course we got to say
most everything is on the table
we have been able to study this bug
because it's gotten out beyond China's
borders and so far it looks like it is a
natural corona virus it looks like it is
a natural corona virus or it's man-made
no it is not man-made from most of the
science that we have seen so far not
every scientist will agree with that
conclusion but you know until somebody
comes up with a striking discovery the
consensus is that this is not man-made
ok fair sir by the way that's
interesting for you to say that because
there's a lot of people that are saying
it is man-made and it is intentional
that leads me to the next question how
much of what is going on right now is
due to a president like Donald Trump
who's his entire career has been based
on the art of the deal to be able to
negotiate and strong-arm his opponent
based on the kind of leverage he has so
he decided to go against the biggest
opponent of us which happens to be China
and he used every single leverage
knowing how much business China does
with us knowing how much import we do
from they're relying on US economy so
the more and more tariffs he put China
said if this is a kind of a game you
want to play you know China has always
been a kind of a person that they don't
fight like you head-on they typically
fight by using whether it's proxies or
you know oh we didn't do it that our
hands weren't touching that that's not
on us how much of it has to do with them
using coronavirus as a method to
retaliate to Donald Trump's approach of
negotiation yeah I don't think that this
is about Donald Trump at all there's a
lot that we can say about the origin of
virus and maybe we should circle back
because a lot of people say well because
this probably wasn't engineered it was
just sort of like naturally occurring
you know it jumped to humans at that wet
market in Wuhan well maybe so but
there's a lot of science that says that
it wasn't Patrick they didn't come from
there because there are a number of
initial patients who had no contact with
that wet market and although if you go
back to weeks people were saying you
know the idea this came from a lab was
conspiratorial
this could very well have been the
release of the natural virus from one of
those two labs that people have been
talking about one of those two labs near
Wuhan is the Wuhan
Institute of virology it's a p4
biosafety lab that's the highest level
of safety in China has told us that they
stored for 1,500 varieties of
coronavirus in that lab and so a lot of
people are saying well this is an
accidental release this gets to a number
of different points that eventually I
will answer your question but look at
what happened this has been you know a
bug which has ravaged China and Chinese
leaders have known that what they have
done though is really striking so for
instance they knew about this in Beijing
sometime maybe first week of December
probably in November in November the
second week of December maybe the third
week leaders in Beijing knew that this
could be transmitted from one human to
the next because doctors in Wuhan knew
that by at least the second week of
December but China's leaders didn't
actually admit this to the world until
January 20th and that is that's there's
a time gap there now just sort of
sitting on that information would have
been highly irresponsible but it's much
worse than that what they did was in
that interim where they knew that this
was contagious one person to the next
they actually tried to convince the
world that it was not human to human
transmission and we saw this for
instance in that January 14th tweet from
the World Health Organization which said
you know based on the information from
China we see no clear proof that this is
transmitted from one human to the next
the reason why that's important is
because Beijing actually tried to lull
the world into a sense of false sense of
security and at the same time Patrick
Beijing was really working very hard to
prevent countries from imposing travel
restriction
in China the way this bug got out of
China was people people who travel
Beijing did two things during a critical
period it it tried to deceive the world
about how this was transmitted and it
made sure that countries did not prevent
people arriving from China now I don't
know what was in the mind at sea jumping
the Chinese ruler but he saw clearly
what the coronavirus did to his own
country it crippled China so if he
actually wanted to [ __ ] other
countries he in fact would have done
exactly what he did so we have to be
concerned that this has nothing to do
with Trump I think that it's because see
Jinping realized how bad things were in
China he wanted to level the playing
field the geopolitical playing field so
he allowed this virus he actually
deliberately took steps to push this
virus outside of China to infect and
hobble other societies that has nothing
to do with Donald Trump this was C
Jinping taking a bad situation and
trying to turn it to China's advantage
those are pretty powerful worth what you
just said right there going you just
said intentional so this was not
accidental this was intentional done by
them
this was an intentional spread of the
virus beyond China now I think about
certain are you about I don't mean to
interrupt when you say that what level
of certainty do you have in that
statement it's just an issue of analysis
that when you look at what they in fact
did there is no other explanation for it
other than that they intentionally
wanted this to spread beyond China
because this is this is not just a
question of keeping it secret because
they were embarrassed that would have
been bad enough that would have been
highly irresponsible but when they then
tried to tell other countries oh don't
worry about this this can't be
transmitted human-to-human what it did
was it actually took other public health
officials and other countries heads did
not take those precautions that they
otherwise would have adopted and we also
know something
similar happened with their infection
and death statistics and we heard the
White House coronavirus task force
coordinator dr. deborah birx talk about
how they looked at the statistics from
China in terms of new cases and deaths
and they said oh this is like SARS which
was the 2002-2003 epidemic which
although it had a high mortality rate
was not very contagious so basically
what aging so what would the White House
did was essentially say okay we don't
have to take certain precautions it was
only after the u.s. saw what happened in
Italy and Spain that they realized that
they had a far bigger problem on their
hands that this would become not just an
epidemic in China but a global pandemic
it would affect the US and that's why I
think the White House took precautions
much later than it otherwise would have
so you could all that stuff together and
the question is well why would they Jing
do this I can't think of another
explanation other than that they saw
that they had an opportunity to [ __ ]
other societies I'm not saying that this
is a bioweapon I don't think that it was
but what they saw after it hurt China
was that they decided that they were
going to spread through the rest of the
world Gordon before I go to the next a
conspiracy to ask you about is if that
is a factual statement of six weeks how
are they held accountable by the world
tribunal you know what is the level of
accountability to them that all the
other countries can come out and say
listen you cost us a lot of money is
there any way of holding them
responsible for waiting six weeks well
there's a number of different ways to do
that there are some cases in US federal
district courts in Florida Texas and
Nevada I don't think they're going to
get anywhere because there's something
called the foreign Sovereign Immunities
Act you just can't go out and sue
another country in US federal court
unless you can get around some
exceptions it
you can take advantage of some
exceptions there's also the
International Court of Justice but that
won't work because China has to agree to
jurisdiction and of course it never
would do so but countries are in
possession effectively of assets of
China for instance China is holding more
than a trillion dollars worth of US
Treasury bills and and notes so we can
take those just with the flick of a pen
and other countries can do the same
thing so there's a lot there that can be
done and I'm not saying that the UI
should do this by itself I don't think
we should because China would say that
that was a repudiation of debt they
would slam us for being irresponsible
custodians of the global financial
system but they would be able to say
that if we took this action in
conjunction with the issuers of other
major currencies so for instance Ottawa
London Brussels Tokyo if we did that in
connection with them then that's
somewhat of an effective measure now we
can't confiscate enough of China's
assets to compensate us for the economic
damage that we've suffered but
nonetheless we need to do something to
deter China and other bad actors from
doing something like this again you know
we'll never get compensated for this
we've lost lives you can't do anything
about that even with the economic damage
you know China doesn't have enough in
terms of assets but we do need to deter
China and one other thing patrick and
that is that what China's leaders did is
a crime against humanity if it isn't
then there is no such concept and there
is no such thing so I think countries
need to hold see Jinping and other
senior Chinese leaders responsible and
if we can ever get our hands on them we
need the 21st century version of the
Nuremberg trials and what does that look
like what could I look like that could
look like what we saw with German
leaders with Japanese leaders after the
Second World War and no one of course
wants to do this but we've never seen a
crime like this in
history no country has ever attacked
every other country and that's what
China has done um it's hard for us to
grasp the the magnitude of what's
occurred but unfortunately that's the
conclusion that we have to face and you
know going forward for our children
forget ourselves but for our children
and for the rest of the world we need to
impose a cross on China so that no
regime ever does this again there's a
big difference between Germany and Japan
versus China because neither Germany nor
Japan had 17% of world GDP at the time
when we did that you're talking about
you know what this almost reminds me of
when you're going there it's almost
reminds me of the whole too-big-to-fail
type of situation because on one end if
you do anything to them how many
economies are tied to China where China
definitely knows that because you know
there's a game of leverage and they know
their level of leverage because as much
as we're talking about masks this and
China this and China debt what are
getting masks from them we're relying on
them on pharma were relying on them on a
lot of different things so do you think
for them when they're sitting in the
boardroom and nobody else's around the
big decision makers they're saying let
it loose relax for six weeks let it get
bigger
let's hurt some of these guys for them
to really know how afraid they are and
they're gonna do nothing about it
because they're relying on us on X Y Z
and because of that if I even think
about doing anything to us we're gonna
hurt them because they're gonna make
sure we have to stay in business to do
what we're doing on a daily basis for
the world to survive do you think they
weren't that deep into processing this
before they made the decision to let it
relax for six weeks possibly you know I
don't know all I know is there's no
other explanation from you know there's
other than a deliberate release how they
got there you know I don't know but you
know Patrick I think we have to worry a
lot less than we normally would first at
first glance thing yes we're critically
reliant on pharma and that we've got to
reduce regardless of whatever Haiti
bushland that's a big No
it is a big number but we can do it
because they are not the world's only
producer of active pharmaceutical
ingredients and you know it'll it'll be
hard but eventually we've got to do this
anyway but the one thing that we always
think about we think oh China's through
the engine of global growth and so
therefore the world is reliant on it
that's not true
China is not an engine of global growth
yes they've got a lot of growth but
they're not the engine because to be an
engine of global growth a country has
got to buy the goods and services of
other countries to create growth
elsewhere and what China has done
through predatory trade policies and
through the theft of intellectual
property has taken growth from other
countries so yes countries have
relations with with China Australia for
instance sells them a lot of iron ore
but that iron ore is put into products
that end up Beano in the shelves of
Europe and the United States so I think
that essentially Australia will be
selling to India or Vietnam or someplace
else for sales to the US these global
supply chains if they are forced will
readjust and they're already doing that
anyway for a number of reasons you know
see Jinping has been pushing companies
out of China also president Trump's
so-called trade war has been pulling
companies out of China I think that that
process will accelerate because of the
corona virus epidemic we are going to
reduce our reliance on China as a
producer of pharmaceuticals and
obviously medical protective equipment
so these things are going to happen
anyway but I think that they're
certainly going to be accelerated and
they should be accelerated I don't think
they're the engine obviously I know u.s.
is 100 percent the engine there's no
question about that I'm 100 percent
capitalist I we escaped Iran to go to
Germany refugee camp to come here
because this is the American dream
nobody wakes up and says the Chinese
dream they say the American dream it's
only one kind of a dream but 1.6 billion
is a lot of people you know when you can
produce things for nothing by a
communist that government ran on a you
know wink wink
but allistic economy controlled by
national I mean so it concerns me to
know 17% and it concerns me to know how
many countries are relying on them but
that's fine let's continue I'm sure
we're going to come back to this topic
again next conspiracy
the death toll ok the death toll you're
hearing some people talk about the fact
that look 99% of people that died in
Italy the number one cause wasn't
coronavirus they were there for another
case and two had other health symptoms
which they had gone to the hospital
before but it happened to be that they
also got coronavirus because maybe their
immune system wasn't that strong so they
caught something so then the hospital
had to put it that the reason for the
person dying was coronavirus and that
spikes up the numbers and it scares the
hell out of everybody around the world
how much credibility do you put on the
topic of the fact that people who have
died they didn't all necessarily died
due to coronavirus it could have been
other reasons yeah I'm sure that in
certain cases a corona virus was only a
contributing factor you know I'm also
sure that a number of people who have
died you know they weren't getting
autopsies especially in an emergency
situation they could have had corona
virus and are not counted as corona
virus cases so you know Counting of
cases in an epidemic where there's a
medical emergency you know society on
the verge of collapse you know
statistical accuracy is probably not at
the top of the list of priorities of a
government in that case and you know we
know for instance in Wuhan you know that
was authorities there were being
overwhelmed so accurately counting
coronavirus cases not not important for
them they were just lying finding we
were just trying to sweep up corpses
from the streets and hospital floors
what do you think they are you talking
Italy who is they
Oh in China in Wuhan in the early days
of the outbreak the authorities were
just completely overwhelmed
you had people literally dropping dead
in the streets you had corpses on
hospital floors for more than 12 hours
so this was a system that was being
overwhelmed
and the point I'm making is there were a
couple of reasons why the statistics out
of China out of Wuhan are not accurate
one of them is just that the authorities
just did not have the capability to
accurately count victims but also there
was deliberate falsi and of those two
cases of those two reasons deliberate
falsehood was certainly I think the more
important in terms of distorting the
death toll and it toll and the number of
infections how much do you trust the
data that we're getting from us on cases
to death toll how much credibility do
you get to that data well you know we're
doing the best we can and as I mentioned
there are a number of reasons why we
won't ever get an exact accurate tall as
I mentioned you don't do autopsies on
people who have died so this is this is
a case of you know testing and whatever
our numbers I'm sure lagged the real
situation but that's true in every
country I don't think that there is an
attempt to underplay this but we did see
that of course in China because there
are there is a lot of into a lot of
evidence that shows that indeed those
death toll numbers could not have been
true could not be accurate okay
okay next conspiracy is there any
linkage between coronavirus and 5g yeah
you hear this a little bit
I actually I mean I'm not a scientist I
don't know but I would be very surprised
if there were because I can't think of
why there would be a linkage between the
two so my view is that that's a
conspiracy theory and unless someone
comes up with proof and I don't think
that they will we can just discard that
one who would be the right person to
talk to about that by the way that's not
politically connected to a organization
that's funded by the government or some
big name that's funding and behind
closed doors that the guy's not going to
tell the truth could be the right person
to talk about that you know I don't know
I mean you have to find basically
someone who was an epidemiologist of a
colleges and also an expert in
telecommunications and I don't think
such people exist and by the way you'd
have to find someone who wasn't working
for a telecom company who wasn't working
for you know that person you know I'd
love to have that person but that person
would be very interesting to sit down
with because we you know we want to sit
down with people who are promoting the
5g side but they're profiting from it so
what they really say anything bad about
it and then there are those that are
working for a nonprofit that's being
funded by some of these bigger
corporations that are selling 5g so
would they really say anything to the
man that's cutting the check I don't
know so okay let's go to the next topic
fair enough
a lot of people are talking about 5gn
coronavirus because the whole radiation
and how it's right eating up the process
next is coronavirus a method of
eliminating the older population to save
country's money because all this
healthcare cost is really coming from
those that are above 70 75 years old and
maybe this is going to allow us to
indirectly depopulate to help the world
economy go better is there any linkage
between those two no but I will say that
there are more than just a small number
of people in China who actually think
that this was a way to get rid of the
elderly but that's complete conspiracy
theory and it's just there's that's
that's just not the case
okay next so far we've got six of them I
got seven more to go so okay we already
covered a seventh one let me go to the
next one okay
next one's a little tricky and so it's
almost like the next four are combined
so I'll kind of say it then
in a way that maybe you'll see where I'm
going with this so a couple cup of data
that shows up the World Health
Organization the number one funder is
the US government I think the number is
six hundred million dollar know the
exact number what I think is around a
six on a million dollar number this
second largest contributor to the World
Health Organization is a man named
gates okay so this man named Bill Gates
if you've never heard of him he's very
rich he's very powerful he started a
company called Microsoft maybe you used
it in the past before windows etc etc
Bill Gates in 2015 gave a TED talk
regarding the biggest threat being
pandemics and how that's something we
need to be worried about but also in
2011 he did an interview with dr. Gupta
of CNN I think it's February 4th when
they did an interview and a lot of
people were talking about the fact that
Bill Gates biggest messaging is
depopulation
so what I did is I went on Google I
typed into words did Bill Gates say to
depopulate the world so the first thing
that pops out is Snopes so I go to
Snopes
and I pull it up and it says inaccurate
false then it puts the transcript on the
bottom which I have it I'd like to read
it because this leads me to a question
here the the question asked by dr. Gupta
is 10 billion dollars over the next 10
years to make it the year of the vaccine
what does this mean exactly
Bill Gates over this decade we believe
unbelievable progress can be made in
both inventing new vaccines and making
sure that they get out to all the
children who need them we only need
about six or seven more and then you
would have all the tools to reduce
childhood death next word uses reduce
population growth and everything the
stability the environment benefits from
that etc etc so then I went online to
look at this video I went and typed them
to follow onwards on Google and the
words were this is what I searched I
typed in I want to get the exact words
that I have here Bill Gates dr. Gupta
reduced population 2011 those are the
words I put on Google the first thing
that came at the top was the Snopes that
said it's not factual it's false the
second link that came up was a CNN link
to the article and the interview of
February 2011 when I clicked on it the
link was a dead link then I tried it on
my phone then I tried it on another
phone to
abed link then i had one of my employers
from Norway who uses a VPN from Norway
to try to go log in from a Norway VPN he
was able to get into the site when he
gets into the site his link with the
transcript was there but the video was
taken down you couldn't watch the video
so after I researched him did some
research we finally found the video and
that exact video between dr. Gupta and
Bill Gates where he talks about reducing
population growth you know a big part of
this when you look at a China buying a
big part of Africa because of natural
resources this is not something that's
private the world knows about this it's
not like I'm just throwing a something
out there that's a non factual that's
factually you can kind of see the amount
of property in Lander binder the
countries that are growing the fastest
population-wise most of them are in
Africa not saying all of them but a lot
of them are in Africa
seven point six percent growth as Siri
you know four point three percent a u.s.
I think it's at one point three eight
some not one point oh eight to one point
three eight and I think China's at point
three eight right now give or take some
time they're saying it's negative an S a
number you're seeing how much do you buy
into the idea that Bill Gates and the
vaccines and the pandemics this was all
orchestrated by the powerful people who
are kind of preparing for this to come
up to introduce a vaccine to the world
it's almost like here's the problem the
Hegelian dialectic this is the problem
blame Johnny I have the solution I am
the hero how much of it is that or do
you think that's a conspiracy theory
yeah I don't I don't think Bill Gates is
trying to reduce population by and I
can't quite think of the word but I I
don't think that Bill Gates's is out to
kill people or whatever
Bill Gates probably believes that there
should be fewer humans and he would like
to improve human health but that doesn't
mean that you he's trying to improve
human health and vaccines to sort of
reduce the overall number of people I
mean I would disagree with him on
certain things but I don't think he's
malevolent okay so zero credibility
there on you
with that 0/0 cape so let's cross that
one out okay next the World Health
Organization you keep hearing about Ted
Rose O'Donnell and you're seeing a lot
of friendliness with him in China and
he's sat down with Xi Jinping you've
seen this before it's now I'm not the
first person that's bringing this up how
much a World Health Organization is
being controlled by the influence of
China on what to report what not to
report slow roll you know the dates at
first it's not that big of a big deal
you know it's okay and then US shuts it
down and oh my gosh US is racist and
they don't care about Chinese people how
could you do something like this and
then they said no it's a serious
pandemic the timing was very often the
world relies on this World Health
Organization our World Health
Organization Ted Rose and China embed
together so they certainly appear to be
that way Patrick um you got to look at
what the w-h-o did in this circumstance
and it is
there's no adjectives in the English
language which describes how bad Ted
rose and the w-h-o were so for instance
I talked about that January 14th tweet
where the WH O's propagated help China
propagate the notion that there are no
human to human transmission of
coronavirus where a wh oh I'm sure knew
that there were how could they not know
about it I mean there are World Health
Organization they've got doctors also on
January 10th WH o came out with the
statement to support China's goal of not
having countries imposed travel
restrictions on arrivals from China so
you put those two things together and it
shows that the w-h-o was very much
supporting Beijing's initiatives and
Beijing's initiatives had to be
malicious also you know Ted Rose did a
number of other things so for instance
in January he delayed for as long as
possible
WH OS formal designation of the corona
virus as a public health emergency of
international concern also he delayed
for as long as possible the WH OS
designation of coronavirus as a pandemic
which eventually occurred I think on
March 11th we saw Tedros in Beijing at
the end of January talked about how
other countries should emulate China's
system and talked about the quote
unquote superiority of China's system
which is thinly veiled that failed
attacked on democracy and then of course
w-h-o has very much been supporting the
notion that China's statistics are
accurate
none of those route would be I think
actions of the organization that really
was dedicated to stopping the virus from
infecting people so you put that
together the one thing you can say is
that if you took the Communist Party of
China and the World Health Organization
together they're responsible for this
taking this which should have just been
a local outbreak in Wuhan or maybe even
who Bay Province and making it first of
all a nationwide epidemic in China plus
also a global pandemic none of those
last two things would have occurred had
not these two organizations Communist
Party and w-h-o acted together so you
can you can argue about who's more
responsible and I think of course it's
the Communist Party but the point is
w-h-o helped spread this coronavirus
around the world and so that its actions
on balance have been maligned and that
leads us to a number of conclusions
about what we do you talked about the
funding of w-h-o that's right the u.s.
by far is the largest funder we put 440
million dollars in the WHI last year you
add Bill Gates that's a lot of other
money we shouldn't be doing that why why
would what's them everything to me is
about motive right everything is motive
we get married why do you get married
there's a motive why do you ask a girl
out well there's a motive why does she
say yes motive why do you buy a real
estate motive why do you buy a car
motive why
we're closed motive what why do we do
anything there's a motive behind it it
doesn't mean all the motive is negative
it just means there's a motive behind it
some days I'm positive okay but what is
the motive between World Health
Organization protecting China that's
what I'm curious about you know I don't
know I don't know Ted Rousseau I'm not
in his head so I can't tell you what his
motive is but you know you can say that
China lobbied very hard for his election
as director general of w-h-o he has very
leftist tendencies maybe there's an
answer in there you know it's a question
I understand why you're looking at
motive but you know loaded is one thing
that you know is really hard to
ascertain with certainty because as I
said I don't know in fact what C Jinping
was thinking I don't know in fact what
Ross is thinking but I don't really need
to know all I can see is what they did
and that's really where we can see the
crimes of that they've committed so I I
don't know motive but as I said I don't
care
yeah only reason I ask is because if
somebody is working closely with Ted
Rose and let's just say they're in a
meeting and there are 40 50 of them and
they're on the inside and they know the
decisions that were made there's no way
in the world Ted the Rose is the only
one that's making a decision I I trust
there's another 20 30 40 people that are
in the know of why the decisions were
made somebody in that group has to be
furious because someone in there a lot
they lost somebody or it affected
somebody or they were affected because
their elderly parents were relying on a
retirement plan now they have to work
harder or one of their relatives lost a
bit someone has to be furious on the
inside with Ted Rose to be able to come
out of salus and I don't think you're
doing a good job just like this 37 year
old doctor out of a you know Wuhan who
came out it was a whistle blower to
China and said this is not we're not
doing the right thing he ended up
passing away he disappeared I don't
recall that but I the only reason I'm
asking motive is because I do believe
everybody at some level has
level of decency to say I just don't
think we're doing the right thing now we
got to do something about this and you
know especially this magnitude this is
not a small thinker this is a very big
thing here someone has to come out of
some what really happened well you know
Bruce
Alwine al Ward who is you know generally
been described as the number two and
w-h-o his formal title is senior advisor
to the director general a couple days
ago he came out with an interview where
he said you know it was very important
for us at an early stage of the outbreak
to be able to study this so we needed
China's cooperation which is really what
his message was so I suppose you could
say that for some people the w-h-o they
were saying well we got to be nice to
China to butter them up so they'll allow
us to go to study it but you know as we
just talked about WH oh they stiffed
armed w-h-o in Wuhan so whatever the
motive was and and that's really pretty
you just said WH o sniff harm WH oh no
no no try to stiff arm WH oh ok
preventing them from an adequate
opportunity to study the for the virus I
suppose you know one could say that
maybe that was what they were thinking
but you know it's very very difficult to
discern motive what we have to do is is
look at what they did and what they
should have known at the time that they
committed certain acts and that needs to
very dark conclusions about not only
China but about the w-h-o one of the
most annoying things that my dad did to
me is hold me accountable I hated it I
couldn't stand it when I was in the army
I couldn't stand being held accountable
to formation and you got to get in and
four o'clock and you got Iran and you
got a report accountability is very
annoying accountability also builds
leaders and accountability builds trust
one of the thing that seems very common
here that's missing is accountability it
concerns me when I even brought it up to
you earlier I said how she trying to be
held accountable at the you know a world
tribunal and you're like well it's not
real we have to figure out a way to get
past this I
you said we need to maybe go back to
wouldn't you know Nuremberg and Japan
and you know Germany all that stuff but
if there is no accountability why
wouldn't I do it again if there's no
consequences why wouldn't I
it's like it's a slap and a hand it's
okay okay I no problem you're okay if I
do this again I'm gonna do it again and
again and again because you need me so
where does accountability come into play
here yeah well you know that's
absolutely right and that's why I said
we need to impose some cost because if
we don't do that they'll do this again
you know I suppose the one thing that
will happen
and this is something that is within our
power to do is that countries are going
to start isolating China for four
decades for five decades countries have
tried to integrate China into the
international system they thought it was
a positive good and because of that they
overlooked a lot of irresponsible and
dangerous conduct on the part of Beijing
because they wanted to encourage to
entice China so that it would in mesh
itself in the you know rules norms
conventions treaties but you know it
hasn't worked and what we're seeing is I
think people starting to understand that
china is not reformable
and if China is not reformable that
needs to the conclusion that we need to
get China out of the UN out of the World
Trade Organization out of the World
Health Organization and just start to
isolate it and I know people don't want
to do that but you got to remember you
know we always think you know China
should be moving on the right path if
you look at what China did in the SARS
epidemic of 2000 to 2003 it was really
awful but as awful as it was its
behavior in the corona virus epidemic of
2019 - you know 2020 is it's been much
much worse than it was and so we've got
to understand that our idea of engaging
China just has not worked and we've got
to try something else and I'm not saying
I can't hold my hand over my heart and
saying that isolating china will be any
better I think it will and that's a long
conversation in and of itself but we
have to say that what we have
julie has not worked it's encouraged
China to be more belligerent more
provocative more hostile more dangerous
so we've got to do something else I
agree and it has to be some strong
measures it can't be light you know it
has to be some real measures for them to
know we can't keep doing this okay so so
the next one here for you this this
one's going to be probably a five-second
answer for you and we'll move on with
this one but some people wanted me to
ask I'm asking this for you and is this
does this have anything to do with so
many powerful people that were linked to
Epstein and Clinton and and what
happened there to the point where it's a
full-on distraction and it has something
to do with China or you give it zero
credibility zero okay let's move on I
told you it's going to be five seconds
next how much of this has to do with
China realizing because I think they've
even said it one of their military
leaders has said that we cannot go
against us when it comes out to power
over military they'll crush us we don't
have that kind of a military that US has
there's no way more we can compete with
them so they took a bigger part of their
resources to want to invest not in
traditional warfare but more in
biochemical drug trafficking poisoning
environmental destruction and computer
virus dissemination how much credibility
do you get to that hundred percent
hundred percent we all we have to do is
listen to what Chinese leaders have said
themselves Chinese military officers
have talked about this you know and we
had seen what what China has done so I
think that essentially we've got to be
really concerned about what you know
they call three Warfare's or
unrestricted warfare which is the title
of that book from two Colonels who are
now two generals so yeah they have been
trying to undermine our society and you
know we don't really have to you know we
can see what they've been doing but we
don't really have to speculate two
months because last may May 2019
people's daily which is the most
authoritative publication in China it's
the self-described mouthpiece of the
economy
people's daily carried a piece that
declared a quote unquote people's war on
the United States and Xinhua news agency
also carried that the Xinhua is official
Chinese government media outlet so
they've declared a people's work
I mean how clear do we want them to be
you know we say that they're not
transparent but as you know people have
said they Telegraph their punches and
that's exactly what they did this time
you know we live in a democracy we may
not like our congressman or senator or
governor or our president but we know
that they're legitimate because they
were elected in China and so we don't
have propaganda but in China when you
have an insecure small ruling group
propaganda is the most important thing
and so they can come up and say these
ludicrous things and and we Americans
are really good at ignoring it by saying
oh they can't really believe that well
yeah they really believe it they
propagate these narratives because they
believe is absolutely critical to the
survival of the regime
you know we Americans ignored everything
that Osama bin Laden said and did in the
1990s we should not be ignoring what
those who are hostile to us are saying
and so we should be paying attention to
what the Chinese have been saying and it
is really belligerent Wow okay so I'll
follow up with a question on that go to
the next one here why why why does it
feel like whether it's the media whether
it's many of these politicians or even
some of the folks who are billionaires
from New York or elsewhere why does it
seem like there's a underlying level of
discomfort with putting too much blame
on China and holding them accountable
and almost protecting them saying that's
not nice you don't talk to them like
that these are good people why would you
do that why is there such a movement
going on and it's very subtle you almost
can't catch it if you don't pay
attention to that way why is that going
on why do you think well here again
we're dealing with other people's
intentions but my guess is a couple
things
of all we live in a highly partisan
atmosphere right now and so people are
just using whatever they can to club
President Trump so that's I think part
of it also because in there there are
elements in American society that have
gotten really rich off of China and so
they don't want that to change so you've
got people on Wall Street yet
people in boardrooms chambers of
commerce that they may seem much more in
common with their fellows in China than
they do with other Americans so there's
an elitism which you know it's it's
typifies of course at Davos so I think
that that's part of it as well
but you know it's really dangerous
Patrick because what we've got right now
is we have a common enemy that enemy
means is harm and that enemy is
attacking us and whether we like him or
not we've only got one president until
January 20 2021 and that means that
we're going to have to rally behind
President Trump we're going to have to
unify because we've got to protect
ourselves because our Republic is at
risk we tend to think of America as
powerful but you look around America
today we've got Americans dying we've
got an economy at a standstill in many
locations we've got a society that is
paralyzed and we have a common enemy
China so we Americans have got to sli's
up and realize there's some pretty
dangerous folks out there and we don't
get together we're gonna lose the
American experiment I agree
question a question for you on the next
conspiracy how much how much of this is
the media sensationalizing over
sensationalizing the credibility of a
chronal virus to hurt the economy and
lengthen this process the longer it
hurts the economy to eventually lead to
President Trump not getting reelected is
there any credibility to that
I don't do domestic politics but you
know the media is the media they Wilson
sensationalize things and all parts of
the media will of course tend to do that
I think you know most members in the
media are responsible but you know there
is that sort of tendency to say this is
brand-new or whatever but this is a that
where we're dealing with something which
creates fear and that is always going to
magnify whatever you know irresponsible
tendencies there are in human being so
we we have fear for a real reason that
is that this is a dangerous pathogen and
until we understand it I don't get too
concerned about overreaction to it I'm
much more concerned about the under
reaction now we may be able to undo some
of the measures that we have taken to
beat the virus I mean and people who are
much smarter than I am we'll be able to
talk about that but nonetheless until we
can see a way out of this we've got to
be very concerned because this bug is
highly transmissible and it's also
lethal and it's not just what happened
in our society take a look at Italy take
a look at Spain take a look at China
take a look at South Korea all of these
societies have gone through crises and
we've got to be concerned what might
happen next are we next one here are we
potentially at the beginning of a world
war three being created and if not will
the next World War three be looking
similar to what we're currently going
through meaning it being a bio warfare
type of a thing that we'll be dealing
with that's very possible
as we started out with your first
conspiracy theory I don't think this was
a bio weapon but you know and a lot of
people you go back six weeks ago you
know back maybe last week and people
would say oh look you know bio weapons
they aren't really
practical you know what why have one
well what we have seen is this
coronavirus probably not a bio weapon
but what it's done is it is paralyzed
societies and I'm sure that China and
other countries have seen what a
biological agent can do so this wasn't
even a weapon in all probability but
look what it did to the United States we
have you know we have ace Nimitz class
carrier the Theodore Roosevelt now
sitting in Guam taken out of action
because some sailors on it have
coronavirus I think the Chinese have
recognized that because they talked
about it in their propaganda you know we
have a biological weapons convention the
United States as a party to it China's
party to it but unfortunately there are
no inspection regimes in that a
convention and we have got to make sure
that it does because right now we have
seen the power of a biological weapon
not a biologic I'm not saying
coronavirus is a biological weapon but
this is what could be what the world's
future bio weapons look like just a
simple virus if an evil empire is
watching this there's a few then one of
them is north of South Korea if some
evil empires are watching this this is
leaving a lot of strategies for other
countries to want to use this as a
potential method in the future forget
about just being China this is the third
it's it's almost as if you know the TV
show when the first came out a was it
not cops was it not America's Most
Wanted what was the one that would show
how people were committing the crimes in
a way they were teaching people how to
become criminals non criminals were
saying well that's a pretty good way of
going and robbing a bank very creative
Oh si si si si yes so this this is one
of those things that's teaching a lot of
people what is potential to go out there
and do
here's another exactly here's another
conspiracy theory tell me if this is a
conspiracy or it's 100% fact factual
does China have a million to three
million people at concentration camps in
China
over there that is not a conspiracy
theory they are detention facilities in
what China calls cynjohn which is the
northwestern part of China the local
inhabitants say it's not China that it
is a separate Republic called
East Turkestan but there are detention
facilities there we don't know the exact
number of people in those facilities but
the lower estimates are 1 million and
the upper estimates are what you
mentioned 3 million and these are they
fit the definition of concentration
camps and we know that this is part of
China's policy to eliminate Weger
culture and eliminate Islam from China
so this is horrific is anybody doing
anything tonight or can they be held
accountable to that to be audited or not
really they can do whatever they're
doing right now well this is a crime
against humanity this is what as bad as
the Third Reich did before it started
the mass exterminations and what China
has done and D Pablito are dying in
those camps because Beijing has been
building crematorium there's been
killing associated with this it just
hasn't been the march you into a gas
chamber type of killing but it's its
extermination of a culture slowly and we
know that people are being killed so
this this is a crime against humanity
and there's not too much that the
international community can do is
certainly not very much the
international community has done but
Secretary of State Pompeo to his great
credit has talked about this and at some
point you know this is one of those
things where by itself it's not going to
get the international community to move
but when in conjunction with you know
the initiatives against the Tibetans
which are similar you know the attacks
on Christian churches you know all these
things that are occurring together
including releasing this virus on the
world these are the types of things
we've taken in the aggregate are going
to get the international community to do
something to start containing China to
start not enriching it with trading with
the rest
so I think that we will gradually I hope
sooner but I think that we will
gradually see a new attitude on China
which is going to be we're going to get
to the place where we were with the
Soviet Union in the took a long time
you know George Kennan had to ride his
long telegram of 1946 and his ex article
in 44 in foreign affairs of 1947 took a
little bit of time for the United States
to get to the point where we saw the
Soviet Union as an adversary I think
we're getting there to China about on
China really fast it's actually not a
bad thing the fact that that's happened
with the majority I think that's a good
a healthy level of paranoia is a very
good thing for nation like you said I'm
not much concerned about overreaction
I'm more concerned about under reaction
which is a powerful statement you made
over here today so okay so look I got a
different question for you now we're
done with the conspiracies we can go
just to some questions for you you're
from China you live there two decades
your father's Chinese why do you not
like the country your father is from
what do you have against China
I mean you are but you are half Chinese
what do you have against the country
that you know your family's from yeah I
have nothing against China I love China
I have a lot against the men and women
who rule it as the Communist Party so
this is something where it's very
different no we talk about China and
that's a sort of shorthand but the
Communist Party isn't China and the
Chinese people are first of all the most
direct victims of the Communist Party
and because they are it means that
they're one of our most important allies
because you know the Communist Party is
reaching out and causing harm not just
to the Chinese people
but to us as well and you know if you go
back before the corona virus epidemic we
Americans sort of looked at what was
going on in in the camps that you
mentioned it with the Weir's we looked
at the Tibetans the Christians people in
Hong Kong people in Taiwan and we said
oh that's over there but right now we
have seen through the deliberate actions
of the Communist Party that they have
reached out
and hurt Americans killed Americans and
so this is no longer just them over
there this is them in our society you
know just to kind of give us a
perspective when you lived it for two
decades what was the timeline what years
were you there okay I lived in Hong Kong
from 1981 to 1991 between 91 and 96
lived in California but most of my law
practice was in China so across the
Pacific an awful lot and then from 96 to
2001 lived in Shanghai so and then after
that I gave up practice of law
this was my practice was was focused on
on Hong Kong China and the region but
you you actually said some you said the
fall of China is coming you predicted it
back in old one I mean that was a I do
believe you said something about China
in 2001 was your first prediction you
made right and I wrote a book called the
coming collapse of China was published
July 2001 and in it I said that the
Communist Party would fall by in a
decade so I was wrong on timing
I didn't happen to I didn't happen to
foresee the 2008 downturn which I think
certainly materially strengthened the
Communist Party for a number of reasons
but I think that it is still coming and
you know it's not about me it's about
what we can see on the ground in China
that there is a fragility to the regime
and you know I can't I can't say when
it's going to occur but we got to be
concerned about a week China which i
think is much more concerned in it than
a strong China when for for somebody who
has never been to China was never lived
in China know there's a difference if
you've gone there for business trip for
a week or two weeks versus living there
from 81 to 91 in there from 96 201
you've lived there you have a day-to-day
life you're working there can you give
us a glimpse of what the day-to-day life
of a living in China looks like like the
biggest difference between US and China
you come home you why
sports you watch TV how many TV channels
do you have how much are you being
brainwashed how are you being
brainwashed what do you have access to
from China what kind of channels if I'm
at a hotel in China do I have access to
ESPN can i watch what does it look like
what is the what is it like living there
compared to us well when we live there
there really what in me of course it was
different to you it was more prosperous
more developed but China was what's
going through sort of like a renaissance
when we lived there there's a lot of
optimism I can remember when we first
moved there as August 1996 and ice my
wife was said she's on the phone she
said mom China's not communist anymore
and I happen to agree with her and one
could make the case then that a lot of
people did that China was moving in the
right direction and yeah the China was
just different I mean they had better
food but you know pretty much it was it
was it was you could see the optimism in
society as you could see in America
these days it's I think it's different I
mean China has become much more
prosperous so it is more developed but
it's it's a debtor place because see
dripping believes in absolute control
over society so we are seeing things
like the social credit system which is
going to be nationwide pretty soon we
can see extraordinary attempts to
control people so it's a it's a very
different place and there's I think the
the optimism that was there two decades
ago is is not there now and part of it
that it is going to be very different is
that the Chinese economy was not doing
well before the coronavirus but was
brought to a standstill
and indeed is deep in contraction so
that is a new factor there and so it
makes China I think very different from
the US this is a very technical question
but probably the most important question
I asked you in the interview has your
experience with China a totally gone you
to a point where you no longer eat
Chinese food
no you
paroled well you know Chinese food is
great I love Chinese okay so okay so
social media question for you I'm just
curious with this one here if Facebook
if YouTube if Twitter if all of these
apps that we use in us were available in
China the last ten years if all of these
social media apps were available to the
public in China the last ten years do
you think the pandemic and coronavirus
would have gone to the point that it is
today
well if they were uncensored like they
are holy ah yeah i think i think that
the Communist Party would have acted
very differently because they would not
have been able to hide things like they
did I mean they're one of the things
that see Jinping has done in the corona
virus epidemic is to impose
extraordinary information controls now
they did that of course when the virus
broke out but they also they had a brief
period of like three or four days of
relative openness from January 22
January 26 and then they went back to
controlling the narrative again and we
know that because the Communist Party
appointed its leading group on
coronavirus under siege in paying
basically what's happened is he sort of
bypassed the bureaucracy and the
Communist Party has set up these groups
on the economy or whatever
well they set up one on the coronavirus
and they announced the roster on January
26 and it was a nine person group of the
group there was only one person was a
public health official and even she I
think her degree was not in public
health though I'm not positive about
that but we do know that it was heavy
with propaganda officials the
vice-chairman was Communist Party's
chief of propaganda the chairman of the
leading group was the premier of the
country who was basically a political
hack and there were a lot of propaganda
types on it which showed that see
Jennings priority
was not ending the epidemic but was
controlling the narrative and since that
time there had been evidence of this
extraordinary secrecy campaign so
they've just gone back to the old way of
doing things so yeah things would have
been a lot different if there were
Twitter and Facebook and and there was
just an open and free social media but
unfortunately that's not the case
I I think if US was to negotiate now
with them and if China wants to do any
kind of trade deals do you think it'd be
a good idea for President Trump to say
you got to have Free Press and you have
to allow every single one of our
platforms in your country with no
censorship or else being doing business
together
yeah I mean that would be a good thing
to do but see jumping would never agree
to that because he does believe he
believes that he should have absolute
control over the party that the party
should have absolute control of her
society so he's never going to agree to
that you know we've got a face one trade
deal sian January 15th I mean who knows
whether China is going to adhere to its
obligations but phase 2 is just not
going to happen
largely because it is they they kicked
the hard issues down the road and see
Jinping is just not going to give up on
them and the issues that that they
kicked down the road like state
subsidies or a lot easier for him to
deal with and what you just talked about
which is open and free media that is
just completely antithetical to cecum
Kings conception of the Communist Party
I'm from Iran I'm born in 1978 I was
born in Tehran at the peak of the
revolution when it was taking place with
scene Omar Xfire were three months after
I was born the Shah was in exile and it
was the largest coup you ever saw nine
million people revolted against the Shah
and a lot of the things that you're you
know seeing you're talking about the
kind nothing was happening to this
extreme extreme in Iran at all the
economy was doing better women were free
they could go out there and you know
vote they had freedom they could do
pretty much every courier they didn't
have to get married you know 13 years
old he had raised it to 18 years old and
then Khomeini comes in and threw a rebel
spreading tapes the people revolted
against the regime until it eventually
flipped wasn't the best thing for them
that's why I got this guy's picture in
the back obviously there's a reason why
the showers and my painting in the back
what are the chances of the people of
China getting so sick of it would they
create their own cool and go against the
regime and if they do how likely is it
that they'll be successful well you know
the they did they were they tried that
in 1989 in a sense they didn't actually
in 1989 the genesis of this was
basically unhappiness about the economy
which then was booming but there's a lot
of inflation but what happened is
through Communist Party hardheadedness
people that started talking about the
big issues about democracy about
freedoms and that's when you know we saw
not only in Beijing but in 370 other
cities in China people took to the
streets right now we are seeing some
really interesting trends and
developments so for instance you were
talking about the death of dr. Lila when
long was one of the Wuhan eight when he
died there was white-hot sentiment
throughout social media in China people
were you know they started that hashtag
I want freedom of speech and also they
started to adopt as their anthem that
politically impactful song from lame is
Arab do you hear the people saying and
that was a clear message to see Jinping
especially because the kids in Hong Kong
had adopted that as a protest against
China so it was unmistakable what people
are trying to were saying now there been
a lot of times where people in China had
gotten really upset the Communist Party
and that anger for one way or another
melted away but what's different now
Patrick is that you've got an economy
which is basically collapsed if their
word isn't a perfect timing bill what
you're saying right now when do you get
the job that's the best time to do it
it's a time where I think people are not
going to
the argument that the Communist Party is
the one to ensure prosperity because
there's no prosperity you have you know
you can see what's happening in our
country the same thing is happened in
China only earlier but you know you've
had an economy which is probably for the
first quarter this year down 25% maybe
thirty percent year-on-year which is an
enormous number
they won't report that of course but
you've the people's livelihoods are at
stake you know so many small businesses
in China have closed like they've closed
in our country so this is sort of like
the tinder for an explosion whether it
happens or not I can't say at this time
but people in China have been talking
about quote-unquote China's Chernobyl
and and that of course is the reference
to the nuclear plant accident in 1986 in
the Ukraine which is generally thought
to be the event that sort of triggered a
long slow burn to the fall of the
Communist Party
here's a question for you
how much of exposure or presence do we
have with the CIA in in China right now
do we have a big presence there or not
really I don't know but I think the
answer to your question is not really
about at 18 months ago or so trying to
execute it somewhere between 20 and 30
CIA agents I mean first of all you you
had a number of presidents before Trump
who just put China very low in the
priority so the CIA just didn't have
that much in the way of resources and
China to begin with and then China goes
in and just kills literally kills on
dozens of them and so I don't think they
found that about well is that verified
of killing bezants it's been widely
reported in a Wall Street Journal and
the rest of it so how did we beat ali-a
towards that no known retaliation why
don't ask me I mean if I were president
there would have certainly been there
certainly would have been costs imposed
on China for doing
but you know China's occupied a special
place in the American foreign policy
establishment which is the reason why
we're in such trouble as we are but you
know I don't think the CIA dancer your
question I don't think the CIA has had
the opportunity to rebuild in China and
you got to remember that China's been
tossing out Western journalists who
aren't CIA but that also reduces our
ability to look into the country I mean
sorry go ahead so you know our
visibility of the China right now is not
very good which should lead us to
believe that if we can't understand
what's going there then why should we
have you know robust relations with them
here's where I was going with this if we
have the right CIA agents there by the
way we need to really invest in a major
major major I would be recruiting agents
left and right to send them there and I
would do it in the most strategic way
and start them early and have them go
through the educational system etc etc I
mean you have to be doing that right and
a way to protect yourself long term and
I would do it in a way to get them
involved in the executive side to have a
lot of involvement there but that's a
complete different side long term wise
here's the question I'm asking about the
CIA technology is more advanced today
than it's ever been before right if
these folks say the Millennials the Gen
X is because that's really the best foot
soldiers you're gonna have to update us
on what's going on just like today if
you do something nowadays it's the
Millennials and the Gen Xers and a
founder generation they're the ones that
are telling us what's going on with the
camera being on and you know tick-tock
and videos everything right if
technology is as advanced as it is and
we have some presence there with CIA how
hard would it be for us to bring a
OpenVPN line and spread that amongst
everybody there to have Facebook YouTube
Twitter I mean we have some of the most
brilliant minds in the world you mean to
tell me we cannot get Internet there and
fight it so quickly so if they're doing
what they're doing we're gonna put
millions of cameras to work by having
this younger generation who will revolt
you know the older folks will not remote
because they have more to lose
younger generation they've always been
the ones that have been able to create
the revolution where there was in Iran
whether there was any kind of a movement
you look at it's always the younger
generation that's well even if you look
at Ron Paul or Bernie Sanders their
biggest momentum creators for who
younger generation right if we can get
technology there with the right VPN
whatever measures it takes to start kind
of seeing what's going on I think that's
going to piss them off the cuff'
government's gonna piss them off then
it's gonna get the people who are
skeptical whether the government's doing
the right thing we're not off China and
maybe they at least do the people saying
we're just sick and tired of it we got
to make a change here and yeah that's
the only way I feel safe for long term
of doing business with China that's the
only way I would feel safer yes and and
there are NGOs that have talked about
developing the means the technical means
of jumping over what's called the Great
Firewall and so there there is some
effort there could use a lot more push
from the federal government you know
there's something else that can be done
and that is shortwave radio which is
what we used against the Soviet Union
China can can because it's got the Great
Firewall can block the internet but they
can't block shortwave radio as a
practical matter so there's a number of
things that we need to do to be able to
get through to the Chinese people
because ultimately the Chinese people
are our greatest ally because we've got
a common interest we've got one group
that is oppressing them and causing
death in our country and that's the
Communist Party of China so we should be
looking to our friends the Chinese
people look when we lived in Iran we had
two channels right and the rich people
had a satellite and you would always oh
my gosh you have satellite and look at
this you can go watch movies and there's
kissing and there's this it was like oh
man rich people can watch crazy movies
you know poor people cannot you know and
you go to your friend's house who had
satellites and they lived in this city
called GaN bead there was a city in your
own called Gandhi which is pretty
interesting that was a rich people city
and we had a friend that lived there we
go there's a look at us we have a salad
don't tell anybody because we could get
in trouble and I think I think that's
you know I think that's which
whatever we do in China whatever we do
with Russia I think that people need
that because we need to get more
documentation of what's going on we're
getting a glimpse of it right now but
not at the measures that we need to to
get that back to what it needs to be so
final exercise here with us but before I
go into this final exercise is there a
what do you see with the foreseeable
future how long does this isn't going to
last what do you when do you see us
going back to work and is there any
positive outlook you have of how things
are going to turn out the next three six
nine twelve months well I sort of think
the virus does burn out during the
summer and you know as we're talking
about it might not I mean this is a bug
that likes hot weather so who knows what
it's going to do you know what I think
that we can see a couple things that are
occurring in China because they're
obviously ahead of us so for instance in
Wuhan where this thing started that's
sort of the bug has burned itself out
and so lot is just slowly getting back
to normal and you know they just opened
up the barricade so people and move on
can actually travel to other parts of
China if they've got a green code you
know they get green yellow red depending
on their health so if they got a green
code they can they can actually leave so
it's sort of getting there but the
problem for China right now is that the
bug has I think jumped to cities on the
east so for instance in Shanghai at the
end of last month they started closing
down tourist venues that had just been
opened a few days before so there's a
real indication that they have got a
problem there and you can sort of see it
in their statistics which they're
issuing on daily infections they seem to
daily infections both all of them basic
and asymptomatic and and symptomatic
are going up so I think that there's a
second wave that's hitting the second
and third wave they've been hitting
peripheral areas to China Singapore Hong
Kong Taiwan South Korea so it's probably
going to hit China as well it's probably
well developed there so China is sort of
where the rest
the world is going which means for us it
you know New York the bug will burn
itself out
I mean coronavirus will jump to other
cities like it's doing so it'll burn
itself out in those other places as well
you know I think that maybe by the
middle of June we'll be through this but
God help us next fall that that was your
attempt at giving a motivational speech
which maybe you need to listen to a
little bit more Tony Robbins to pick up
some abilities on how he does it I don't
know maybe you need to kind of work on
that so by the way just something for
you to be thinking don't let your wife
discourage you from what thinking about
the comedy said because let the jokes
come out don't don't let her to see you
not to let the jokes come out okay last
part here I'll give you some names and
give me the first word that you think
about whatever would they think about
give me the first what we call this a
speed round
Bill Gates Oh too much money Elon Musk
too much idiocy idiocy yeah I mean the
the early Elon Musk
you know great man going into space
Tesla I think that's terrific the
problem though is that I think fame has
gone to his head and you know it was
typifies what we saw two three months
ago with that dance he did in China I
mean it just shows you that I think he's
going too far I I don't think he's gonna
make money in China with electric cars
for a number of reasons I think this
could be where he really gets a real
lesson you know it's like sort of famous
gone to his head so you were really
frustrated with his dance moves so yeah
if he improved his dance moves would you
not call him an idiot so or would you
change no it's still going to attend
okay got it
maybe we need to recommend some nice
choreographers to hire he can afford it
so Ted Rose odd-odd hanim yeah I think
that he needs to resign if he doesn't
resign we need to defund the w-h-o what
he did was despicable so I don't have a
good word to say about him and I had
times I'm not able to think of I don't
think there you know he leaves me
speechless so is it fair to say you
don't have a picture on that bookshelf
of viewers behind you
of jedrus yeah you're not gonna have it
open but it is my daughter my wife my
in-laws a couple of me you know friends
from college
no Ted Rose no Ted Russ well it is what
it is
Margaret Chan ineffective ineffective
gchem Bing criminal analyst on Steam and
I spent Anthony Fawlty uh hero you know
moon jae-in another criminal
Mujahid wants to he wants South Korea to
be merged into North Korea and probably
on North Korea's terms so he wants to
end democracy in South Korea I mean he
knew jayan is one of my favorite topics
actually so it's hard to come up with
just one word for him
but I think that he's dangerous he's no
friend of the u.s. he would love to be a
totalitarian he is moving China and
moving south korea away from a liberal
democracy back to an authoritarian state
so what nice things can you say about
him ranging theme liar I mean he keeps
on saying oh you know while we would
never spy for Communist Party well I Got
News for you the 2017 national
intelligence law of China requires every
Chinese national every Chinese entity to
spy if demanded and besides in the
Communist Party's top-down system you
can't resist a demand from the Communist
Party
Brent himself is a member of the party
so you know I put him into the basket of
dangerous individuals last but not least
Lee wen Liang Pierrot
people hear it clearly hero
and he sacrificed his life to try you
know he went to the you know he went to
everyone talking about the disease he
did that a great personal risk to
himself eventually as a doctor he lost
his life treating coronavirus patients I
mean it's just sort of brings tears to
your eye 12 third this has been a very
very insightful and hopefully the
viewers were able to look at some of
these different conspiracies that's
being tossed around and getting millions
of views and getting people's attention
and quite frankly as a putting a lot of
fear in people I got a call the other
day at 11:30 at night one of my friends
was a very successful businessman called
me and him and his wife we're on the
phone I had to have an hour and have
conversation with this person because
they were buying into some of these
conspiracy theories that really were
messing with their heads and it's not
just getting naive people it's getting
everybody to start kind of questioning
some of this stuff because the way it's
being sold it's very convincing so again
at the end here's what I suggest to all
the viewers we're gonna put the link
below of following Gordon G Chang
Twitter handle you can send them a tweet
after watching this let them know what
you took away from the interview as well
as any questions you may have and we're
gonna put the link of your book coming
collapse of China the link below as well
for you guys to purchase any final
thoughts with you before we wrap up the
interview you know our society let me
let me just repeat something that I said
that we're really at risk we are going
to have to band together because you
know as Ronald Reagan said you know
freedom is only one generation away from
extinction
well now it could be a couple of years
away from extinction so we've really got
to get together and as Americans defend
our society and our way of life Gordon
thank you for being a guest thank you so
much Patrick I really appreciate the
opportunity absolutely thank you well
bye so look with all these conspiracy
theories who kept asking me Pat do you
believe this stuff now it's on you to
process it for yourself this man Gordon
shank seems like a reasonable person he
doesn't seem like he's sensationalizing
either one you can process it and
comment below which one did you believe
it which one of them do you still have
your own doubts and if you liked this
interview have two other videos I want
you to watch one of them was with
dannyelle DiMartino booth economists
nine years with Federal Reserve Dallas
who has a lot of insider info on what's
going on with the economy and the Fed
she talks about the aftermath of the
economy post coronavirus must-watch and
the oak but the other one is if you
haven't watched it with general Spalding
from air force who had some insight
dealing with China he lived there to
find out what their world is like if you
haven't watch this one it's a must watch
as well click on either and if you
haven't subscribed to our channel please
do so thanks for watching everybody take
care bye bye
[Music]